The current administration is going to go
down not just as one of the most incompetent,
but as one of the most uncaring and immoral
administrations in modern American political
history.
And why am I saying this today?
I mean, I could really say it on any day.
But yesterday, Vise President Mike Pence went
to the Mayo Clinic for a staged photo op and
he refused to wear a mask.
Now, mask aside.
You could make the argument he really shouldn't
be going at all.
Traveling from Washington, D.C. to Minnesota
at all.
Especially for someone like Pence, who's around
a whole bunch of people all the time, going
to a place where people are being treated
for coronavirus and other serious conditions,
introducing germs, why even do it?
It's a bad idea.
He shouldn't do it at all.
But he went he went for the photo op and he
was told to wear a mask and he did not.
As you can see, if you're watching today,
everybody wearing a mask.
Secret Service, the patient, nurses, people
in the back room.
But Mike Pence not wearing a mask.
The Mayo Clinic tweeted, quote, Mayo Clinic
had informed Vise, president of the masking
policy prior to his arrival today.
They told him, but Pence refused to wear a
mask.
The Mayo Clinic ended up deleting their tweet
about having told Pence about the mask policy.
About three hours after they posted it where
they pressured by the administration, we don't
know.
But that tweet was since deleted by the Mayo
Clinic.
Here is Mike Pence, surrounded by people with
masks.
He's the one guy in the room without one.
Take a look.
Take a listen.
This started with the FDA to release Dr. Marshman.
So it's a protocol on March 30th.
So why didn't Mike Pence wear a mask?
He was asked.
And he says because he is regularly tested
for the virus and he wants to look people
in the eye.
Take a look.
There's some controversy she got here about
the decision not to wear a mask around.
Marcus, the governor and other officials here
did.
Can you just walk us through why you made
a decision not to wear the mask?
Seven, they tweeted.
Well, let me say, as vise president of the
United States, I'm tested for the Corona virus
on a regular basis and everyone who is around.
Is tested for the Corona virus.
And when the CDC issued guidelines about wearing
a mask, it was their recognition that people
that may have the Corona virus could prevent
the possibility of conveying the virus to
someone else by wearing a mask.
And since I don't have the Corona virus.
I thought it'd be a good opportunity for me
to be here, to be able to speak to these researchers,
these incredible health care personnel, and
look them in the eye and then say thank you.
He wanted to look people in the eye to say
thank you.
Does Mike Pence know that you don't cover
your face?
I'm sorry that you don't cover your eyes with
the mask.
You're only covering your nose and mouth.
Someone someone tweeted me about this.
He said, you know, David, maybe Mike Pence
is used to a type of white face mask that
does cover your entire face.
If you guys know what I mean.
That's a joke, by the way.
I think as far as I know, anyway.
So this is one of the dumbest explanations
and this includes the testing thing.
Now, Mike Pence says he's tested regularly
and people around him are tested regularly.
You could be incubating the disease.
It's possible you could be contagious before
a test result would come back positive.
We just don't know.
And of course, Pence is flying around.
He's the last person who should be going to
a hospital without wearing a mask.
If Mike Pence brought an asymptomatic or priest
symptomatic early case of Corona virus to
the Mayo Clinic, do you realize the amount
of havoc that he could personally wreak?
It is infuriating and it is toxically irresponsible.
But they don't care.
Now, what do I think?
The real reason is why Mike Pence didn't wear
a mask.
They manage by optics.
OK.
They want to pretend that we're on the other
side of this pandemic.
They want to pretend like, hey, listen, where
states are opening.
Everything's good.
We're about to win.
If a vise president who has not been seen
wearing a mask for months during the pandemic,
all of a sudden on April 28 for the first
time wears a mask in public.
The optics are not that we've almost won.
Now, of course, we've not almost won.
It would be accurate to realize that we've
not almost won, but it's management by optics
and Pence doesn't want to be seen wearing
a mask.
What I would like to have seen is the Mayo
Clinic simply deny Mike Pence entry.
Now, I know it's the vise president.
I know he flew there from Washington, D.C.
These things are carefully choreographed like
a dance.
It would have been a very bold move for the
Mayo Clinic to do that.
But I find it more bold and certainly more
disrespectful and disgusting for Pence to
go in there without a mask.
You have people who have family members at
the Mayo Clinic with coronavirus family members,
and they're not allowed to go visit at all.
Never mind with a mask because the risk is
too great.
And Mike Pence flies in from D.C. and is walking
around with no mask.
I hope that when this is all over with and
by that I mean the virus and this administration,
and hopefully that sooner than later on both
counts.
I hope we don't forget how incompetent this
administration is.
But I also hope we don't forget how disrespectful
and flat out terrible people this administration
has been made up of, because it is absolutely
and completely disgusting.
We'll have more coverage of this on our Instagram
page at David Pakman show.
Also, follow me on Instagram at David Pakman.
If you're looking for a break from bad news
every day, follow my urge urban gardening
experience, which I am reporting on consistently
on my Instagram page at David Pakman.
We'll take a quick break and be back right
after
The David Pakman Show.